peu
hé hé
[Musique]
non ne cherchez pas un tri de policiers
à tout ce scénario il s'agit tout
simplement d'un rendez vous un rendez
vous avec paul guihard à villiers le sec
un personnage curieux c'est vrai qu'ils
donnent des consultations elle aussi
curieux c'est tout cela sous un abribus
furent bouteurs dame était mme boutin en
patois normand mais enfin qu'est ce que
c'est un rebouteux on met les pas de
corps j'ai bien en tant que vous faites
ça depuis des dizaines d'années j'avais
10 ans quand vous avez commencé avec mon
père comment vous avez découvert ce dont
je joue au basket frère de mon père
louis il était docteur lui et on avait
eu une escalade humain à la maison il y
avait des doigts une escale écumant les
docteurs lula et holt à la maison chez
me fais mon père alors c'est là dessus
et j'ai tout appris
vos premiers malades à l'âge de
dix ans j'avais une dizaine d'années je
travaillais déjà avec mon père voulait
remettre et j'ai tout le temps continue
et que les autres systèmes en meilleure
forme qu'en sédimentent des décors
scéniques leaf à ma façon avec du blanc
d'oeuf mais quand c'est une foulure
n'importe qui une bande depuis de l'eau
salée et puissant cavale après
[Musique]
c'est meilleur que du plant c'est
efficace oui mais rien de meilleur cas
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la médecine
moderne
[Musique]
je n'en parlais pas les toby font comme
ils veulent et moi je suis quand même
parce que vous êtes bien avec les
docteurs du viage la région a bien
surtout avec quel pays via la boîte là
et on peut appeler la police
oui l'autre jour c'était comment je
surveille en nba
les gendarmes qui nous attendent dans le
bureau du directeur je le fais comme ça
pour elle pourrait user de surveillants
il y en a encore un conjoint d'anne rice
écosse et la gueule du loup dit
certainement oui
il avait la suite des fêtes est content
mais ce que c'est légal tout ça au bas d
ici sans trop qu'on peut le faire il
vient mais il y a même trouvé c'est
votre cave ainsi l'arrêt du bus à
winneway ou alors d'un ange voilà bois
recrue lycée berthelot qu'on se livre
quand c'est des bonhommes en fou mais
quand je dis les femmes les emmène
d'abord je ne perds ta pourquoi avec
rudy c'est comme ça que ça se pose quoi
[Musique]
voilà vous savez tout sur quoi le gia
laissons le se faire emmener par un
client maintenant dernier détail si vous
souffrez de rhumatismes ou bien si vous
avez l'épaule démise une seule adresse
paul le rebouteux sous l'abribus de
villiers le sec
[Musique]